ah
toda mi vida desde que tengo memoria
el mundo se ha encargado de decirme que
soy raro que soy un raro una persona
rara
en la escuela mis
mis maestros mis compañeros en trabajos
que he tenido
ex novias
ec suegras ya llegó el raro de tu novio
me cae
y hasta la fecha ahorita que tengo
millones de seguidores de personas que
diariamente están al tanto de lo que
hago constantemente recibo esta
retroalimentación
y la verdad es que sí la verdad es que
si yo mismo me considero una persona muy
rara
si ustedes me conocieran un poquito más
personalmente se darían cuenta así
para empezar soy una persona que tiene
muchísimos muchísimos tics tengo muchas
manías me pongo nervioso y estoy
parpadeando todo el tiempo las manos me
sudan ahí les va una antes de dormir
tengo que apagar y prender la luz dos
veces es un detallito que tengo que
arreglar paso a paso
tengo una fijación muy rara con los
números pares si algo sale impar por ahí
me ponga un incómodo
y ya más grandes rasgos todo el tiempo
estoy pensando en ideas estoy anotando
las porque porque me da cosa que se me
olviden en general si yo reconozco yo sé
que soy una persona inusual
pero aquí está la cosa realmente no creo
ser un caso excepcional no no creo que
es soy el único yo creo que todos todos
todos aquí todos en el mundo en el
planeta tienen sus ciertas rarezas
tienen ciertos detalles que los hacen
únicos que los hacen diferentes a todos
los demás
pero muchas veces nos da miedo nos dan
nervios enseñárselas al mundo porque no
queremos ser juzgados no queremos ser
expuestos preferimos no levantar miradas
extrañas
decidimos esconder estas pequeñas
rarezas que también que tenemos porque
nos da miedo ser excluidos de cierto
grupo de personas
el ser humano por naturaleza siempre
está buscando un grupo al cual
pertenecer
si nos vamos a necesidades muy
primitivas un grupo de personas para
salir a buscar alimento y para huir del
frío y para juntos construir una
comunidad y cuidarse los unos a los
otros y así nos vamos a necesidades más
específicas
buscamos un grupo de personas para
juntarse y entre todos pagar la renta de
una casa
buscas un grupo de personas para hacer
una tarea un proyecto para aprender
juntos para crecer crecer
profesionalmente
y sobre todo buscamos un grupo de
personas que nos brinde ese sentimiento
de aceptación social que nos hagan
sentir que somos parte de algo que
estamos integrados ahí
porque verán estamos tan acostumbrados a
ser encasillados ya ser parte de un
estereotipo que le ponemos un adjetivo a
todo tipo de comportamiento que
observamos que esos de allá esos esos
son emos
así son les pusimos y esos hipsters
vamos a ponerles hip estás todos ahí en
ese grupo reciben este nombre son
hitters y esos este fresas vamos a
empresas esos
y ese de allá
quién sabes es un raro ese está raro ese
no embona en ningún grupo realmente es
raro
lo que muchas veces no nos ponemos a
pensar
es que tal vez el ser raro el ser
inusual en sacarle ventaja a estas
rarezas que tenemos
es tal vez exactamente lo que queremos
hacer porque piénsenlo esta es la
cuestión
todos al menos me gusta pensar que todos
vivimos en una búsqueda interminable de
ser alguien será alguien en la vida de
tener algo que nos diferencie de todos
de ser recordados queremos un
reconocimiento queremos que la gente nos
tope
sin embargo hacemos todo lo posible por
ser nadie
y todas estas cosas que nos hacen únicos
que nos hacen raros que nos hacen
inusuales las aplastamos y preferimos
comportarnos como todos los demás como
nos han dicho toda nuestra vida que es
correcto pensar esas ideas que tenemos
esos cambios de humor que tenemos esos
comportamientos maneras de expresarnos
las escondemos
entonces si nos comportamos queriendo
ser nadie queriendo pasar desapercibidos
vamos a lograr ser a alguien
no sé ustedes qué opinan
yo por ejemplo me dedico a hacer
contenido para internet contenido que
hoy en día es consumido por millones de
personas de verdad diariamente millones
de personas están sobre mi sal pendiente
lo que hago millones de personas se
sienten con la libertad de juzgar todo
lo que hago todo lo que digo la manera
en la que actúo
y muy constantemente recibo este
comentario
por qué
joel llc les explico hago contenido hago
vídeos en la actualidad que se tratan
sobre la cotidianeidad
muchos de estos vídeos los grabó en la
calle lo cual significa que al yo
trabajar solo al estar por mi cuenta
para tener un producto final tengo que
ir invariablemente por la calle hablando
solo con una cámara a un volumen elevado
para que se escuche bien entonces ahí
voy hablando platicando y constantemente
recibo ese comentario de que es raro que
todos te vean así o sea
que eso a mí me daría vergüenza
imagínense peor aún cuando estoy en un
país en el cual hablan un idioma
completamente ajeno nada más una persona
diciendo cosas en voz alta entonces
recibo en sus comentarios constantemente
en la actualidad es muy fácil para mí
decir así como hay siete millones de
personas me respaldan o sea realmente
sabes pero no siempre fue así cuando yo
al principio decidí exponerme al mundo
mostrarle mi cara al mundo del internet
a bien como lo hice de la manera más
niña posible lo hice con tutoriales de
piano yo dije voy a enseñarle a la gente
a tocar piano y pues obviamente te
empieza habiendo muy poquita gente gente
que no sabe quién eres y tienes puro
comentario negativo pero con tono
negativo
y si llega a ver eso una persona a quien
conoces personalmente y luego luego la
crítica es que le pasa que es curioso
que raro quien le dijo quisiera decir
como para que que va a lograr
pero si ustedes luego luego le hacen
caso a estos comentarios negativos
en vez de hacerle caso a sus ideas
de explotar de aprovechar sus rarezas
esas cosas que los hacen especiales creo
que podrían tener buenos resultados
enseñarle sus rarezas al mundo porque
nunca saben cuántas personas en este
masivo mundo se van a sentir
identificadas con lo que estás diciendo
con lo que estás expresando a cuántas
personas van a poder complementar
tales empiezas con 10 personas que
significan contigo y de ahí se
convierten en 100 en miles en millones
entonces no esconden sus rarezas
aprovechen las explotan las inténtenlo y
me cuentan cómo les va muchas gracias
[Música]